[Musik]
louisenlund einst sitz eines herzogs
heute ein privates internat
es ist alles neu also die titel sind
noch sauber die brillen sind nicht
zerkratzt und man kann mit den ganzen
sachen arbeiten die bertolt brecht
oberschule gebaut vor fast 30 jahren
staatlich
wenn man integriert zu wenig die
modernen sachen man benutzt immer noch
schwächer man schreibt immer noch mit
kreide
wer nach luise nun will braucht reiche
eltern oder ein stipendium biburg lukas
seit der neunten klasse geht sie auf das
gymnasium sie und ihre mitschüler sind
in der schwerpunkt klassik chemie bio
und physik vor zwei jahren wechselte sie
von einem öffentlichen gymnasium hierher
hier vergleiche eigentlich hier
funktioniert alles schon deutlich besser
und es ist einfach sauberer ist neujahr
man kann viel besser mit den sachen
arbeiten also ich denke mal es ist klar
dass es dinge gibt die nicht so gefallen
an der schule aber das ist jetzt glaube
ich nicht nur an der bab a
das sind viele schulen in berlin
hongkong geht auf die bertolt brecht
oberschule hier schrumpfen die
jährlichen 35.000 euro aus louisenlund
auf durchschnittlich 8900 euro pro kind
zusammen
nach der zehnten klasse will er sein abi
machen und mediengestalter werden bei
der einschulung entschieden sich seine
eltern bewusst gegen die privatschule
für ihre kinder ja wir haben das
natürlich diskutiert sowohl in der
familie wie auch wir als eltern alleine
so ein langer prozess aber aufgrund der
erfahrung die ich an der privatschule
gemacht haben haben wir uns dagegen
entschieden
wichtiger aspekt war auch die erkenntnis
dass die probleme die auf unsere kinder
zu kommen in den allermeisten fällen ja
doch gesellschaftliche probleme sein
werden
und wenn man die gesellschaft nicht
kennt tut man sich schwer ihre probleme
zu lösen
in louisenlund in der physikstunde sitzt
jörg mit nur drei anderen schülern im
unterricht die 35.000 euro ihres
stipendiums fließen komplett in moderne
ausstattung den unterricht und
unterbringung der schüler
ein gewinn darf die schule als stiftung
nicht machen für björk ein deutlich
besseres konzept der größeren zu meiner
alten schule ist glaube ich dass die
lehrer viel mehr zeit für jeden
einzelnen schüler haben haben jeder
lehrer kennt ein viel besser jeder
lehrer kennt seine stärken und schwächen
der schüler toms klassenlehrerin
jongliert dagegen 20 25 kinder pro
klasse lehrerinnen wie sie werden
dringend gebraucht fast 40.000 pädagogen
fehlen in deutschland ihre schule hat
zwar technisches equipment wie computer
aber zu wenige für 1500 schüler manchmal
ist es so dadurch dass die schule so
groß ist dass man dann nicht so schnell
an die verschiedenen sachen rankommt und
dann das doch wieder vertragen muss auf
andere stunden weil man in dem moment
nicht die möglichkeit hat das im
unterricht umzusetzen
neben lehrermangel plagen viele
öffentliche schulen auch baufällige
gebäude und sanierungsstaus gearbeitet
wird deshalb oft im laufenden betrieb
anders die privaten schulen die
finanzieren sich durch spenden und
schulgeld sind weitestgehend unabhängig
von der politik
zwei parallele welten von denen sich tom
nicht entmutigen lassen will
ich glaube schon dass viele schüler so
die gleichen chancen haben erfolgreich
zu werden je nachdem was sie halt machen
wollen ich glaube das kommt ganz auf den
schüler selbst an
optimismus eines 15-jährigen faktisch
aber deutschland investiert nur 4,1
prozent des bruttoinlandsprodukts in
bildung und das liegt noch unter dem
europäischen durchschnitt